heute diese geschichte ist so
unglaublich 100.000 euro sind nicht
angekommen
ich habe mir den sie haben wir den
beweis gestellt ich habe den beweis
geliefert wo ist das geld das ist david
badens da wird es arzt lebt und arbeitet
derzeit in schweden nachdem er seine
familie in deutschland besucht hat
treffe ich ihn am frankfurter flughafen
bevor er nach schweden zurück fliegt
denn er hat eine echt skurrile
geschichte erlebt wegen dieser
geschichte ist da wird auch noch jahre
später immer noch mit personenschutz
unterwegs aber ein fachmann dann vor
einigen jahren war da wird noch im
medizinstudium als er sich mit einem
biologen anlegte der behauptete es gäbe
keine masern wir und es kam zu einem der
skurrilsten gerichtsprozesse
also holt euch ein ziel entspannt euch
schon mal denn ihr werdet eure nerven
nach der noch brauchen hier kommt die
wahre geschichte über den 100.000 euro
prozess und einem maß an verschwörung
[Musik]
wir brauchen für diese geschichte ein
paar wissenschaftliche basics handeln
wir die ganz kurz vorweg ab die masern
sind uns ja allen ein begriff aber wie
diese infektionskrankheit wirklich
aussieht das wissen die meisten von uns
gar nicht mehr zum glück weil diese
krankheit ebenso selten geworden ist die
krankheit nicht mit diesem typischen
roten haut aus schlag an wofür die
masern bekannt sind die anfangs symptome
gleichen grippesymptomen und werden
daher oft viel bedeutet diesen ersten
fünf tagen vor dem aus stark ist man
aber bereits krank und hoch ansteckend
in köln gab es letztes jahr zum beispiel
ein masern ausbruch der aber zum glück
noch dank aufklärung und impfungen
rechtzeitig eingedämmt werden konnte die
folgen können lebensgefährlich sein
manche können gar nicht aufstellen wir
haben patienten junge frauen und männer
gehabt die in der woche in windeln
gelegen haben und so gar nicht aus dem
bett gekommen sind dann kann es zu einer
schweren gehirnentzündung kommen zwar
einmal akut direkt im verlauf der
krankheit und manchmal das ist so ein
bisschen unheimlich eigentlich dauert
das aber 78 jahre bis die hirnschäden
auftreten in dem fall kann man nichts
dagegen machen das ist eigentlich immer
tödlich diese zwei neuen studien zeigen
außerdem wie die masern auch das
immunsystem nachhaltig schädigen können
sie ist das stichwort also eine art
gedächtnisschwund des immunsystems also
normalerweise bildet unser immunsystem
nach einer überstandenen
infektionskrankheit oder nach einer
impfung antikörper die sich an die
krankheitserreger erinnern und beim
nächsten mal angreifen
durch eine massenerkrankung kann jetzt
das immunsystem aber diese erinnerungen
verlieren und dadurch wären wir nicht
nur anfälliger für infektionskrankheiten
sondern auch das sterblichkeitsrisiko
steigt trotzdem gibt es menschen die
krankheiten wie die masern verharmlosen
ich lade die auch als kind mir jetzt
nicht geschadet wenn das so ist freut
mich dass für dich ernsthaft gut für ihn
und in jedem anderen fall würde ich auch
sagen es ist euer körper macht mit dem
was ihr wollt aber gerade als werdende
mutter ist das besonders frustrierend
denn mein baby kann nach der geburt
nicht sofort geimpft werden dann ist es
erstmal zu jung und es gibt zum beispiel
auch menschen die eine immun krankheit
haben und nicht geimpft werden können
und diese menschen sind darauf
angewiesen dass wir geschützt sind dass
wir gewillt sind das eine
herdenimmunität besteht besonders
gefährlich ist es jetzt wenn menschen
die masse nicht nur verharmlosen sondern
sogar verschwörungstheorien verbreiten
dass die masern da keine
infektionskrankheit sind als ich
ungefähr vier jahre lang medizin
studiert hatte habe ich im internet eine
webseite gefunden von einem typen der
ist biologe promovierter biologe und er
behauptet ganz ernsthaft dass es
infektionserkrankungen gar nicht gibt
also der sagt bakterien oder viren die
führen nicht dazu dass man erkrankt
sondern alle erkrankungen kommen nur
durch irgendwelche psychische traum
unter germanische neue medizin dürfen
solche ehrvorstellungen
infektionskrankheiten wir sind alle eine
erfindung der pharmaindustrie die nur
will dass wir sozusagen uns impfen und
medikamente spritzen damit wie daran
geld verdienen
jetzt hat der mann aber auf seiner
webseite 100.000 euro dafür aus
geschrieben dass man eben eine
wissenschaftliche untersuchung zu schick
die beweist dass die masern als viren
oder als viruserkrankung existieren dann
habe ich gedacht dem zeigt ist ich will
dem das beweisen und am besten will ich
noch dieses geld nehmen und es in
masernimpfungen investieren um diese
impfgegner eben halt mal so richtig zu
ärgern also ich wollte natürlich
provozieren damit eigentlich hatte da
jetzt nicht ernsthaft damit gerechnet
dass diese auslobung von 100.000 euro
wirklich ernst gemeint war dann habe ich
den brief geschrieben habe geschrieben
hier auf dieser web seite habe ich
gelesen dass sie 100.000 euro anbieten
für den beweis der existenz des
masernvirus stimmt das denn wirklich so
man schreibt er mir wirklich zurück und
unterschreibt auch noch ja ich zahle das
geld gerne aus aber bei ihren recherchen
werden sie sehen dass es dieses masern
virus überhaupt gar nicht gibt also ging
david recherchieren er brauchte ein paar
stunden um sechs studien rauszusuchen
stern tv hat das noch mal ausgerechnet
dass ich ein stundenlohn von ungefähr
20.000 euro hatte und dann habe ich ihm
diese diese publikationen mit
einschreiben rückschein zu gestellt so
dass er unterschreiben musste dass er
diese bekommen hatte nicht bei e mail
ich habe das richtig offiziell gemacht
und dann nach ungefähr einem monat oder
so habe ich ihm dann eine mahnung
geschrieben
ich hab da geschrieben ich habe mein
konto beobachtet und die 100.000 euro
sind nicht angekommen
ich habe ja den sie haben wir den beweis
bestellt ich habe den beweis geliefert
wo ist das geld aber dermaßen leugner
wollte diese sechs studien schlicht und
einfach nicht als beweis akzeptiert dann
habe ich gedacht wer entscheidet
eigentlich ob ich das geld jetzt
bekommen oder nicht weil ich kann nicht
eine waschmaschine bestellen und dann
sagen ich bezahlen dafür nicht ich habe
mir das anders überlegt oder die
waschmaschine ist eigentlich ein
trockner oder so da habe ich gedacht das
muss doch jetzt irgendwie mal eine
andere stelle entscheiden
werde mir fiel recht hat also zog david
mit diesem fall vor gericht und zwar vor
das landgericht in ravensburg und war
das ja nicht nur eine juristische frage
war sondern auch eine wissenschaftliche
wurde von dem gericht auch ein
wissenschaftlicher gutachter
hinzugezogen
und zwar der mikrobiologe professor
andreas pott bielski der angeklagte
masern leutner fand es anscheinend nicht
so gut dass wissenschaftliche expertise
hinzugezogen wurde und versuchte sich zu
wehren indem er andere gutachter als
befangen abgelehnt hat und zwar
vertragen jegliche virologie in
deutschland ich bin ja kein
ausgewiesener virologe und ich bin halt
allgemeine mikrobiologie wobei
sicherlich immer die biologie auch für
mikrobiologie mit dazu gehört aber
sämtliche virologen von vornherein schon
mal abgelehnt hatte weil sie ja
sozusagen schon in ihrem namen die
existenz virus sozusagen mit drin haben
und damit apriori voreingenommen sind
wollte und stiften sicher kann sich der
biologe werden also nur damit das glas
es ging hier nicht um eine grundlegende
medizinische frage nämlich gibt es mal
servieren oder nicht denn die gibt es ja
es ging in diesem fall um die frage hat
david mit seinen sechs studien genügend
beweise dargelegt um dieses preisgeld
von 100.000 euro zu bekommen und
professor podgorski kam zu dem schluss
ja hat er in ravensburg wurde dann das
urteil gefällt dass ich diese 100.000
euro bekommen soll weil ich sie mir
sozusagen verdient habe und er war
natürlich extrem sauber vor allen dingen
weiter als auch die weltpresse im
prinzip darauf geschaut hat das war
natürlich für die presse ein gefundenes
fressen
ein impfgegner lobt 100.000 euro aus und
dann holen sie sich jemand auch noch ab
und spendet die dann auch noch an an
masern impfungen aber freunde der sonne
bleibt sitzen
die geschichte ist noch lange nicht zu
ende der masern leutner wollte das nicht
auf sich sitzen lassen und ging in
berufung
der fall ging also in die nächste
instanz die sind dann nochmal noch mal
zu einer gerichtsverhandlung vom
oberlandesgericht in stuttgart und dort
wurde dann anders entschieden und
freunde pass auf das ist jetzt kein witz
ich hatte sechs studien eingeschickt er
hatte aber geschrieben dass er eine
publikation haben möchte und da in der
auslobung von nur einer studie die rede
war da wird aber sechs studien hatte die
nur in ihrer gesamtheit die existenz des
masernvirus bewiesen hatte er aus rein
formalen gründen kein anspruch auf die
100.000 euro preisgeld der impfgegner
bekam also tatsächlich recht vor gericht
weil er wirklich nur aufgrund dieser
semantik tja das eben halt einen artikel
haben wollte er aber sechs bekommen hat
und auch landgericht ausgesagt hat dass
also dieses urteil nicht darüber urteil
aus masern virus gibt es nicht und das
oberlandesgericht hat es dann nochmals
gesagt das urteil geht nur um die
semantik es geht nicht um die existenz
des masernvirus ja ich hab mich
unglaublich über die juristen aufgeregt
ich fand das war wirklich ein komisches
urteil weil es einfach nicht verstehe
also in diesem fall ist es aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht ohnehin
unglaublich schwer irgendetwas mit nur
einer studie zu beweisen also wenn ihr
jetzt schon länger weil es schaut und
wisst ihr ja auch dass forschung sammeln
von puzzleteilen ist und dass eine
studie alleine sehr in irgend etwas
grundlegendes beweisen kann sondern es
sind puzzleteile die zusammenpassen
müssen verschiedene experimente die in
sich konsistent sein müssen um dann ein
gesamtbild zu ergeben da wird versuchte
daraufhin den fall vor den
bundesgerichtshof zu bringen und der
bundesgerichtshof hat das dann nicht
weiter verhandeln wollen jetzt könnt ihr
euch vorstellen was seitdem passiert ist
dermaßen leutner und seine anhänger
verbreiten seitdem die falsch infos dass
das oberlandesgericht in stuttgart und
der bundesgerichtshof beide bestätigt
hätten dass es keine masern viren gibt
was natürlich schlicht und einfach
gelogen ist und hinzu kommt dass er die
dreistigkeit gehabt hat und gemeint hat
auch mal ein gutachten belegt ja das ist
mal wenn wir uns nicht gäbe und ich
hatte dann noch mal kontakt mit dem
richter aus dem landgericht ravensburg
und habe ihn gefragt ob ich den lanka
anzeigen soll ja weil er wegen
verleumdung
wirklich eben einmal das wort im mund
oben dreht das schriftlich tod und eben
halt deutschland weit verbreitet da hat
er sich der damals noch gemeint ist
nicht kriegt damit nur die
aufmerksamkeit die ja eigentlich haben
will ja gut das ist natürlich ein extrem
eitler mensch der der sehr gerne
aufmerksamkeit wollte und das ist ja
jemand der sein geld verdient mit
büchern bücher wie diese hier inseln
völkermord im dritten jahrtausend oder
impfen und aids der neue holocaust es
ist ganz typisch für
verschwörungstheoretiker also achtet man
darauf die aussagen sind immer so extrem
so radikal so empörend dass die meisten
menschen davon zwar nicht angesprochen
werden weil die meisten menschen zum
glück vernünftig skeptisch genug sind
aber diejenigen die sie damit erreichen
das sind dann ganz anfällige ganz
verletzliche personen das sind dann zum
beispiel menschen die selbst schwere
krankheit haben oder jemand in der
familie haben erkranken
die vom medizinischen system enttäuscht
sind und jetzt ganz verzweifelt nach
antworten suchen und dabei wird leider
nicht nur angst sondern auch hass
geschürt
david wurde so massiv bedroht und auch
seine familie
dass er heute jahre später immer noch
nur mit personen schützen die
öffentlichkeit geht
also ich würde es auf jeden fall noch
mal machen ich denke dass ich nicht
wirklich also es geht gegen meine natur
und gegen meine persönlichkeit mich da
nicht dagegen zu stemmen wenn jemand so
einen unsinn behauptet und damit auch
noch die gesundheit von leuten und von
kindern
in gefahr bringt das ist doch nicht
normal also ich rege mich das ist
vielleicht hätte ich darüber auf also
ich lasse das so nicht stehen ich kann
da wird einerseits nur zu gut
nachvollziehen andererseits sehe ich das
ganze auch wieder ein bisschen anders
vielleicht weil schon so lange youtube
machen und über so viele
verschwörungstheorien gestolpert bin die
letztendlich alle eine ähnliche taktik
fahren die verschwörungstheoretiker sind
meistens super provokativ konfrontativ
sie fordern wissenschaftler heraus in
der öffentlichkeit sich ihnen zu stellen
wenn sie dann ignoriert werden
dann sagen sie natürlich sieht die
keiner traut sich mit sie widersprechen
habe ich euch doch gesagt andererseits
will man dann auf sie zugeht dann
akzeptieren sie natürlich so was wie
wissenschaften nicht als beweis so ein
quatsch das kann ja jeder behaupten und
das finde ich besonders gefährlich denn
wir jetzt ein laie dazu schaut dann
steht für die dm zweifel aussage gegen
aussage denn es hat ja nicht jeder die
zeit oder die wissenschaftliche
ausbildung um sich sämtliche studien im
detail durchzulesen oder seitenlange
gutachten das was ich erreicht habe das
war im prinzip dass ich auf den
masernimpfungen und auf die masern als
erkrankung aufmerksam gemacht habe ich
habe keine gelegenheit ausgelassen um
quasi für impfungen zu werben so zu
sagen und ich habe auch irgendwo
signalisiert hey leute was ihr hier im
netz treibt seit damals schön vorsichtig
und ihr könnt nicht jeden mist behaupten
ohne dass euch jemand widerspricht und
dass das auch konsequenzen haben kann
ziemlich persönlich ist dieser fall noch
ein waren beispiel dafür dass man mit
vernunft bei verschwörungstheoretikern
nicht gewinnen kann also am ende sind
nur sie ist die aufmerksamkeit gewinnen
und wenn es richtig blöd läuft sogar
gerichtsprozesse und eine sache darf man
auch nicht vergessen dass sagt david
übrigens auch gerade diese ganzen
extremen radikalen stimmen im netz sind
meistens nur eine sehr kleine minderheit
die einfach nur sehr laut schreit und
deswegen nicht unseren diskurs bestimmen
sollte also der anteil der radikalen
impfgegner deutschland beläuft sich auf
einen niedrigen einstelligen prozentsatz
die meisten menschen
nicht richtig geimpft sind sind es weil
sie vergessen haben weil sie nicht
wissen wo impfpass ist weil sie nicht
wissen ob er noch up to date ist und
fühlt ihr euch angesprochen also haben
alle leute die hier zu schauen
ich kann euch wirklich empfehlen geht
mit euren impfpässe zum arzt und fragt
einfach mal nach ob ihr alle impfungen
bekommen habt und lasst euch nachimpfen
wenn sich irgendwie zeigt dass euch noch
eine masernimpfung zum beispiel fehlt
weil es ist super wichtig nicht nur für
eure eigene gesundheit schützt euch ja
damit gegen ganz gefährliche
erkrankungen sondern auch um die
gesellschaft zu schützen um eure
mitmenschen zu schützen babys zu
schützen die zu jung sind um geimpft zu
werden kranke leute zu schützen
ja auch keine impfung erhalten können
oder denen schlechtes immunsystem haben
also geht einfach zum arzt mit eurem im
spruch und fragt einfach mal nach ob ihr
wirklich alle impfungen habt oder kann
ich nur unterstreichen und wenn ihr
möchtet teil dieses video bitte gerne
ich finde es wichtig wenn möglichst
viele menschen vor dieser geschichte
erfahren würden wir sehen uns bald und
bis dahin bleibt sicher